Who is the god
like Yahweh the god
of wrath the god of Mercy The God
Who reaches down to unworthy people.
Well, good morning. Again Church. My name is John. I get the
privilege of preaching most weeks here and it is
an honor to get to serve our faith family. That way if I
haven't met you yet, please come say hi. I love meeting people love to
connect with you. Especially if you're new, please let us connect you
to our church as best we can today. We're
continuing our series through the Book of Micah. We're in week
three. Now. She go ahead and turn to Micah as you turn
there. Let me get us started by telling you about a man.
I was talking to Alan Rice this week about him a man
named Cornelius Vanderbilt.
You might know that Vanderbilt name Vanderbilt University. Yes. That
is the same. But Cornelius Vanderbilt. He's
most well known for being a business tycoon in
the early to mid 1800s.
And he built his vast Fortune using
railroads and shipping. He was
one of the wealthiest Americans it's ever lived and he
is credited with much of the railroad
system and much of the westward expansion of
the United States back. Then you can point to Vanderbilt
for that.
And his story really is kind of the American dream Lord of this
Manifest Destiny idea where you know, he
knew that he was gonna work hard. He would be able to be successful. He was
gonna make it all of that. It would pay off and he saw
he started in his father's company. He helped build that
up and then began to start all his own new Ventures and
it ended up to this this vast Fortune.
So we kind of look at that and we're like man that that's a capitalist hero right
there. Right? Like he is the guy that where he looks to it's success story
all those things and you add to
the fact that he also claimed to follow Jesus. He was
Moravian. He claimed to follow Christ. So you look at all
that and we could tend to think that surely God was
blessing him for his work ethic and his faith and
look what he was such a success.
When I leave out of that story.
See as Vanderbilt was building his Empire.
What you don't often hear about?
Are the hundreds of people who were killed building those
railroads?
Or the workers who were oppressed and did
all of that hard labor for pennies were treated
terribly.
We always hear about all the good that Vanderbilt and
many others have done throughout history. We're thankful for
a lot of that in America, but we forget
All of the people that they stepped on to
get to their success.
It's maybe not as blessed as we think it is, right.
Here's what God's going to do with this mirror of God's
word today.
She might just shine that into your own heart.
into my heart
to show us
where we might be on the same pathway.
And we'll see a similar situation to what I just described actually in
Micah chapter 2. So if you're not
already there, let's find Micah chapter 2. I'm going to read verses
1 through 11 and show you.
Exactly the same thing.
Woe to those who devise wickedness and work
evil on their beds.
When the morning Dawns they perform it because it's
in the power of their hands.
They covet fields and sees them and houses and
take them away. They oppress a man
in his house a man and his inheritance.
Therefore this says the Lord.
Behold against this family. I'm devising disaster.
From which you cannot remove your necks?
And you shall not walk haughtily or pridefully for it
will be a time of disaster.
In that day, they shall take up a taunt song against you and moan
bitterly.
And say we are utterly ruined.
He changed the portion of my people. He removes it
from me to an apostate or a foreigner. He
allots our fields.
Therefore you will have none to cast the line by
law in the Assembly of the Lord.
Do not preach thus they preach one should
not preach of such things disgrace will not overtake
us.
Should this be said oh House of Jacob?
Has the Lord grown impatient are these his
deeds?
Do not my words do good to him who walks uprightly.
But lately my people have risen up as an enemy you strip
the rich robe from those who pass by trustingly without
the thought of War.
The women of my people you drive out from their delightful houses
from their young children. You take away my Splendor forever.
Arise and go this is no place to rest because of
uncleanness that destroys with a grievous destruction.
If a man should go about an utter wind and lies saying
I will preach to you of wine and strong drink.
He would be the preacher for this people.
There's a lot to pick through there. We'll come back and see all through
it again. But we we need to start by
considering the reasons for God's judgment here.
See if you remember chapter one. We saw this kind of generic judgment
God's gonna bring on his people. They've obviously sinned
here now, he starts to label out some of the specific
things they were doing
And what we'll find here is that there's actually three we're gonna
summarize them into three two of them are going to take today the third one
shows up a lot more later. And so we'll take that later in
the series. But the two that we're going to look at today are
reasons for God's judgment.
The first one is this.
Covetous oppression
first reason for God's judgment on in the nation here
is Covetous oppression.
And we saw it, right?
In Micah's day, there was this powerful group of people abusing
the rights of others.
These were leaders and influential figures that were casting off
the Commandments of God and they were instead living for
their own Pleasures living for their own selfish gain.
brazenly abusing their power
stealing things during the daylight right now. If you're
gonna steal something, it's probably best to do it at night. They don't care they're doing
it during the day because they have the power in their hand. It says
they can do it.
Just a Brazen abuse.
power
but notice the oppression had a source.
It was covetousness.
That's the word in verse 2 to covet. It means a strong desire
for someone else's possessions.
Or even something like to take Pleasure in
someone else's stuff to even lust after
someone else's property.
And this is direct Rebellion.
To the tenth of the famous Ten Commandments the tenth commandment
says do not covet.
Do not Cove at all of these other they list out a bunch of things and they are directly going
against that not only that they're opposing
God, but they're crimes had a
deep effect on other people.
Not just because those people lost their stuff but because in
doing so they lost their identity.
Because remember that's where their status in the community rested.
their household their their Dwelling Place their
land
that they're inheritance came through that and so to take it
away from them meant they they lost their place in
the community essentially.
And so these people were sinning against God and oppressing others
by overpowering them by treating them
unjustly by burdening them unnecessarily all
of that was over them and notice it was all in the
name of economic growth.
Just want more. We want more we want more.
And this is the result.
See, that's why God was going to judge him.
And in verse 5 it says he was going to take their land away and give
it to another give it to an apostate a
foreigner.
Where they wouldn't even be able to own the land in the future. That's what verse 5 means
whenever they were Distributing by lot. Meaning they
were tossing dice essentially that that was how they distributed the
land in numbers.
And God says I'm going to take even that away
from you where you're gonna lose your land now and you won't ever be
able to own it in the future.
And he says that they will not be able to walk around in this
Pride this arrogance that they had before because
instead of what they've been doing to somebody else
to the poor. They've been oppressing and standing on
their neck. Now. God says it's gonna flip around and those
oppressors are going to come on to you.
The enemy is going to overtake you gonna take
you into Exile and you are now going
to have the yolk around your neck.
And it leads to this lament in verse 4.
This taunt song it says not Katy Perry's
fight song. It says taunt song here.
But notice it's a it's a taunt that they apparently had
been saying to the poor before and
the poor were crying out in response. Now, these
oppressors are gonna feel it the same way.
They're gonna cry out in the same way that those poor people
had for many years.
Everything they've been doing to the other people now was going to be done
to them.
Now as we think about how this applies today.
How do we bring this 2700 years to us?
You might be hearing this and reading this like I don't have a problem
with that.
I'm not stealing stuff from anybody.
Not like lusting after vehicles that
drive by me on the interstate. That's not me man. What are you talking about?
This is their problem, but actually when we start to
dig a deeper into coveting.
Start to get to the heart of the matter.
The essence of coveting is that I need
something that I do not
now have to make me happy.
Right. I need something in my life
that I don't currently have yet. And if I get that
thing then I will be fulfilled. That's the essence of
coveting.
So you think about it that way that sucks all of us
in then right?
Because we've all been there we all get there. It gets
to the heart. It's like Jesus in The Sermon on the Mount.
And he says to the people he's like, yeah, you've never murdered anybody. Okay, but
if you are angry in your heart towards them
if you have unforgiveness in your heart towards them then it's just
like you murdered him.
It's as much a sin before God as that
is.
So he says it right here, right? No, you never stole anything.
but think
what's your heart motivation for how you live your life?
Is it greed?
More I want more accumulating.
Is it dissatisfaction?
With where you're at. What what you have what God has given you
is it dissatisfaction? Here's the problem with that what
that means is that you're not then satisfied
in God.
If you're dissatisfied in life, you say well, I need
this. I'm looking for something else to be my joy something
else to fulfill me that I need.
It's saying to God, you're not enough.
That he in his goodness is not enough for you.
Which by the way I'm sorry if you work in
marketing, but this is the whole essence of advertising, isn't it?
It's creating a dissatisfied state
of life.
So all the sudden you finally realizing. Yeah, I really do need to buy Flex Seal.
I never knew that like I just like
that's this point is that there's creating dissatisfaction. So
you think this is gonna fulfillment I need that.
It's just living out what first John 2.
verses 15 and 16 say negatively
It says do not love the world or the things in the
world.
If anyone loves the world the love of the father is
not in him.
For all that is in the world.
Now check this the desires of the flesh.
The desires of the eyes that's the lust the
coveting and the pride of life.
I can do whatever.
Is not from the father, but it's from
the world.
Now we need to be careful to make a distinction here.
Because what this could lead to is like well, I can't
have any desires then.
Just got to kind of lay down and take it right. No, there are actually healthy
desires as well.
I mean just think about it.
a single person who wants to be married
you think about that woman who wants to find a job so
she can provide for her family better like that. That's those are
good healthy desires as long as those
things don't become idols.
As long as you're not coveting what somebody
else has like man, I wish I was married to that but like that's coveting. No,
it's not that it's if it's done in
a healthy way that God gives us good desires.
They're right.
But what happens when coveting starts to enter the
mix?
Is like with Cornelius Vanderbilt?
Coveting begins to lead you towards compromise.
It leads you towards.
Stepping on other people's shoulders to
get that desire that you have.
It leads you to begin to see others as objects for
your pleasure.
Or as something to be used to get what
you really want.
Now you see how this can go really badly, right?
This is where adultery comes from.
Just wanting something else. This is where pornography comes
from that you are used for my pleasure. That's where
underpaying employees comes because I just want more profit. That's
where lying comes from robbery comes from
abuse comes from is that I want something from
you and I'm going to use you to get it.
It all comes from the heart root of covetousness.
Which then if you have any power over someone else that's what
leads to oppression.
It's exactly what we see in Micah 2.
We see it all the time here.
in our lives
Okay, so clearly we don't want that.
That's set this stage for the negative. What do
we do to fight against that selfish desire?
Like what's a practical step that I can take to
combat this coveting that leads to oppression at times
of others.
Now we can take this one way where we go into kind of like the systemic part
of our culture and how the financial system works and we
can get into that and I'm sure there's tweaks we can make to make that better.
But what about for us individually?
How do we as individuals fight covetousness in
our own hearts?
Well, one of our values is a church is reimagine
generosity.
We use everything that God's given us time Talent treasure all
of that for his purposes first that's
reimagined generosity because think about what these
people in Micah 2 should have been doing
the wealthy people instead of taking more
from the poor.
They should have instead flipped around and used
their wealth to bless the poor to care
for them.
Because that's what God intended all throughout his word.
See it everywhere, but just listen to Psalm 82 verses 3
and 4. It says give Justice to the weak
and fatherless.
maintain the right of The Afflicted and the destitute rescue
the weak and the needy
Deliver them from the hand of the
wicked meaning they're already oppressed. You should work to
deliver them from that.
It's not just Old Testament Galatians 2:10. Remember the poor
James 1 True Religion verse 27
cares for the widows cares for the orphans which
by the way were the ones who are the most oppressed back then.
Care for them find ways to serve them
because here's what that sacrificial generosity does.
As we start to to shift our mindset to it
what it does is it counteracts our natural desires
for our own selfish coveting and
greed.
Like when you intentionally make an effort to be generous.
That is the antidote to the poison of coveting.
It flips it and it says I'm going to give instead of
take.
No hear me.
It's not wrong to acquire wealth.
We're not saying anything about that. What we're
saying is you just better hold it Loosely as you
attach deeply to the Lord.
It's gonna call you to give and sacrifice and and use
it for his kingdom Hold it more Loosely as you
attach more deeply.
So when we look at all this, this is a heart check for us, isn't it?
We have to ask the question.
You and I we need to ask the question of ourselves. Is
there any hint of coveting in my
life?
Is there any desire I have that I'm looking for
something instead of looking for God to fulfill it.
I lost this thing and I'm grieving
that loss instead of just saying I'm content with where God
has me.
Is there any hint of coveting? Am I
more focused on things and money than I am on the
kingdom of God.
You know you saw here in Micah 2 these.
These influential wealthy people were were laying in
bed at night plotting how to make more money and
how to to steal more stuff and grow their their
net worth. That's what they were plotting out. What if instead
of scheming at night for ways to climb
the ladder.
What if we laid awake at night devising plans
to help the hurting and the homeless and
the hungry?
And you can't sleep at night not because you're trying to figure out how to grow your business. You're trying
to you're not sleep at night. You're trying to figure out how you can help more people.
See how that complete opposite.
That's the antidote.
The ways to give instead of the ways to
take.
And here's one easy way to get there.
When you remember we said this a lot in the last few months you remember
you're not an owner of any of this.
Like you don't own the clothes on your back. You don't own your house. You don't
own your stuff all your money. It's not yours. God owns
it all.
And what he asks of you to be is a generous steward.
To invest his kingdom in his
vest his resources for his glory.
When you remember, it's not yours. You can be open-handed with it.
Say all right God you use it. However, you want to it's What
First Timothy chapter 6 verses 17 through 19
says this this thought prose should be in our minds as
for the rich in this present age charge
them not to be haughty or prideful or
selfish nor to set their hopes on the uncertainty of
riches.
But to set their hopes on God.
Who richly provides us with everything to enjoy?
They are to do good to be
rich in Good Works to be generous to
be ready to share.
Thus storing up treasure for themselves a good foundation for the future
so that they may take hold of that which is
truly life.
It's an interesting comparison. He says that your stuff and wealth
and riches in this world is not truly life.
Living for the kingdom of God as a steward is life.
Let's see Abundant Life.
Now I want you to think about something.
About how you are feeling already having heard
all of this.
Think about how Micah's original hearers would have
been hearing all of this.
Do you think they would have been enjoying hearing this
judgment on them coming? Right? Well, they
have the engine. No, they would have been like
What's wrong with you Mike?
I've been hurt it would've been critique.
In fact, they did in verse 6. I tried to get
him to stop.
But that leads us to the second reason for God's
judgment here.
It's what I refer to as ear tickling unbelief.
We saw Covetous oppression. As one reason God's gonna bring judgment on his people
irickling unbelief is the
second we're going to talk about here now when the world is that
So like when the old man comes up to you and takes a quarter out of
your ear like that. You're tickling kind of feel like no that's not where anything we're
talking about with actual hands and ears we're
talking about.
The fact that Micah's audience did not want
to listen to God's word through Micah.
In fact, they would much rather have listened to what verse
11 says this guy preach about which beer
and wine to drink.
You see that right? That's what it says verse 11. If a
man should go about an utter wind and lies saying I
will preach to you of wine and strong drink. He would
be the preacher for this people.
Let's be like you come to church and they're like here's this
one. And this one is where you spent why she picked this one like it's just meaningless,
right?
But that's what they wanted to hear.
See, that's the point.
In verse 6. They said Micah don't teach us these hard
things.
Micah why can't you just make us feel good?
That's the ear tickling side, right? It's supposed to make you
feel better. Whatever you're listening to.
I said Micah. Can you not just tell us what we want to hear? But listen,
that's the whole point of why they got in this mess
right? They said that because they didn't believe they
were at any risk.
And Michael why can't you just make us feel better?
Verse 6 disgrace will not overtake us Micah don't you know your
theology?
I mean my Micah don't you know God's not going to
judge us. We're his people remember Exodus 34.
What's your number? That God is is patient. He's compassionate.
He's slow to anger. He's abounding his
steadfast love Micah. Don't you remember what God
said about himself. He's not going to do anything to us. We're his
people.
Why would you tell us he's going to judge us? There's no way
he's going to judge us.
The problem was that they were only half right about the character of God.
Because Micah says you're right.
God will bless those who follow his
ways who walk uprightly he
will bless those.
but Micah in verses 8 through 11 looks down at these people and he says
You're not.
You're not living up rightly. Look at what you've been doing.
He says you are stealing land. You're taking clothes
right off people's backs. You're repossessing widows
houses. You're forcing children to live on the
street.
So Micah looks at them and he says it doesn't matter if you're a Hebrew
or a not it doesn't matter. God will
never bless that kind of life.
Whoever your father is, it doesn't matter if you're Abraham's lineage God's Not
Gonna bless that.
But don't forget where all this ties back.
See the root of their sinful Behavior.
The reason they were living like that was they
did not believe the right things about God.
right
They completely abandoned the Covenant principles.
God had given them.
they misunderstood and said
God will ever judge us.
They didn't get God's character, right? They thought
he was this when he was actually this.
And now even further they embraced these ear tickling
prophets just told them what they wanted to hear meaningless nothings.
Church do we
not see this happening around us just as much
today.
Do we not have people in our day who are who are
putting God in a humanly constructed box that limits
him to certain things.
Do we not have people saying?
Surely God can't be like that.
Whenever his word says that's exactly who he is.
Or people who only focus on the blessings of
God.
without the standards he has
or people who look the other way whenever they see oppression
happen and they just kind of like
Not my problem.
Do we not have people limiting God's love to those
who look and act like us.
Or that God loves us because fill in
the blank.
Or we just assume that we are always right
and they are always wrong.
Just look at our political system, right?
So not only all that. We also at the same time have
people who are claiming to be followers of Christ who are repelled by
the truth of God's word.
They're just looking for that irickling feel. Good message.
now
let me clear. I'm not saying that a preacher has to be a jerk to
be faithful to God's word.
You don't have to be.
But the reality is that there are people who don't like to be told that
parts of their life are wrong.
Who don't like to read God's word and say Jesus
you came and you told us to die to ourselves.
I don't like that. I have to give up a lot of things
or or they don't like to be told that we're all on Mission
that you are included in the mission of God, just like I am every one
of us.
Was happening back then.
Is still happening today?
That's why the Apostle Paul told young Pastor Timothy.
This in second Timothy chapter 4 verse
2. He said hey Timothy preach the word.
Preach the word.
The word of God be ready in season and out of
season meaning all the time reprove rebuke.
And exhort with complete patience and
teaching.
So Timothy's reading this and he's like, hey Paul, you know,
I mean, I'm gonna have to say some hard stuff man.
God's word got some hard things and I've just say that stuff.
Paul's like yeah
Verse 3 for the time is coming when people will not endure sound
or healthy teaching but having
itching ears. That's the ear tickling idea. They will
accumulate for themselves teachers to suit their own
Passions.
We'll turn away from listening to the truth and wander off
into myths.
One of my favorite preachers is Charles Spurgeon. He restated
that verse in his own distinctive way as he
does. He says a time will come when instead of
shepherds feeding the Sheep the church will have
clowns entertaining the goats.
And so instead of slipping into that pitch.
We must be anchored in the truth of
God's word.
We cannot deviate from it. We commit
to that here. That's one of our values as a church anchoring truth,
right? This is the source of all of
our Doctrine all of our Lives because
remember what got them. Astray was misunderstanding God's
character.
They didn't have a full understanding of who he was so
that means we must get our theology, right?
Our study of God our understanding of who God is we've got
to get that right but hear me.
It must be a humble theology.
What I mean by that is that we as humans are
willing to change and willing
to live differently according to
what God is like.
See we can get all our theology right on paper.
We have great discussions about Theology and Doctrine and we can debate and
have great discussions all over that. We can then put our
Doctrine badge up on the bulletin board. Like we earned it
with Awana. We got it. Like I've got it figured out.
But James 1 says that we're not changed to buy it,
then we are actually deceived by
it.
James 1:22 through 25 says be doers of
the word not here is only
not study yours only not just understanders only
but be doers of it be changed by
it because here's what happens you can.
You can grow this Megamind like head where
you know it all but your heart is the size of
a marble.
You can know it all.
But not live it at all.
That's a dangerous place to be.
And so this is humble theology.
Where as you rightly desire to learn more about God
that is good. It's right the nature and
character of God when you know more about who he is understand who he is, but
then at the same time we learn how
to align ourselves with that truth
of who God is
We're willing humble to change even if it moves
us outside of our box.
Even if it challenges something that you grew up hearing over
and over again.
Even if it pushes you to confront that
Covetous oppression in your own life, even when
it pushes you past where you thought you would ever go. However
God's word moves you it's willing to
change your life to match it.
humble theology
To open your hands up and in case of
Micah 2 to reimagine your generosity that's saying
maybe it's not all about just what I can get more and more and more and accumulate and
grow and store up barns, right? That's not maybe it's
not about that.
That's the world says that.
Even churches said that in some ways. It's not about that. Jesus says to
be generous to give to to count your
life as nothing and and give it all away.
to fall in
maybe he means that.
We're willing to change.
So Micah.
God used him to point out to these people.
Their Covetous oppression their ear tickling unbelief, and
he said judgments coming.
But we're not finished with Micah too yet.
See, there's one more piece of this puzzle here, and this is meant to
Spur us on.
I know all of this and really most weeks of Micah will
feel this way where it's all judgment judgment judgment judgment.
And it's a part of who God is yes.
but don't miss
The end chapter 2 don't miss these threads
throughout.
Because here's what happens as you look around as as you watch a
culture go further and further away from God
as Micah watched his people drift from God's covenant
as we watch a culture drift towards destruction
as we see that man what it does. Is it
stirs in us a desire for something more right?
Like we look around and we say God. When are you going to
bring the the judgment on the oppressors? When are
you going to fix things when you gonna make it right? When are we
going to get out of this prison that we're in that's where oppressed
by the enemy and then the world like how God are
you going to do this? And when?
Micah points us to the source of God's blessing here.
We saw the reasons for his judgment. But now he says hey hold up. There's
actually a source of blessing.
a source of blessing here
These are the two verses I didn't read at the beginning on purpose versus
12 and 13. Look at what Micah writes.
I will surely assemble All of You O Jacob. I
will gather the remnant of Israel. I will set them
together like sheep in a fold like a flock in
its pasture a noisy multitude of men.
He who opens the breach or the Gap goes up
before them? They break through and
pass the gate going out by it their King
passes on before them the Lord at their head.
So we're gonna get into this you're gonna see how this is building us
towards something, but this is interesting because in verse 12 God's talking.
Right, he's saying here's what I promise to do for my people who
trust me and what he's doing is he's promising a Deliverance.
When he looked at this the source of blessing. It's this
Deliverance that God has promised for his people.
That's what he says here with this remnant.
This group of people who are not Believers in name only. These are
people who actually trust God.
He's going to gather them and say I'm gonna pull you together
like a flock of sheep.
Surrounding them protecting them. They're in
a pasture. They're joyfully noisy. There's no
fear. There's only pleasure. There's excitement. There's
there's all of that that happens around this.
Man, when you look at this, this is not the same picture that Jesus paints and
Luke 15 of the Good Shepherd.
Remember that Parable the one sheep wanders off
and the shepherd loves it enough to go after it and
get it and when it finds it, it pulls it back and they
rejoice and they celebrate and they have a party.
This is the same idea.
And we church we have the privilege of looking back at this through the
lens of Jesus.
We put on our Jesus glasses and we see what he's talking about
here in Micah 2 what we know then is coming forward
for what for us. One day church. This whole
thing is coming from Jesus as
our Good Shepherd to save us redeem us and
collect us just like this.
That if we're a part of his faith family by trusting
his life death and Resurrection in our place.
Man, what we're going to see happen is he's throwing this sheep party
just for us as well as worthy of Celebration.
He's going to gather Us in he's going to make us a noisy
multitude where he's protecting us. His arms are around
us. This is coming from our Good Shepherd.
But that's not even all.
Because in verse 13 Micah starts talking God talked
in verse 12 now Micah starts talking and he's referring
to Yahweh. Who's not this time a Shepherd this time. He's
a warrior who's going to battle for his people.
Because remember chapter one we saw God come down off the
mountain and he was treading on our high places. He was
he was kind of judging by stepping all
over and showing his power that way now it
shifts to where he's breaking down the walls of
their prison and he's leading them out in
glorious Triumph.
I remember as a kid when I went to San Francisco with my
family. We went to Alcatraz Alcatraz is
the island prison off the coast of San Francisco and
it is probably where the it is
where most probably the famous most famous
prison escape ever was attempted.
And so these men were trying to break out of Alcatraz.
They didn't undercover of Darkness. It was all hidden. They were
trying to stay in the darkness and the Shadows because they could have
been shot on sight.
It's incredibly interesting story to walk through in all of
that. They tried to break out of that prison.
But that's not Micah's prison break here, right?
See that was done under the cover of Darkness. They were trying to hide
so that they could get out. This says their
King passes on before them. Yahweh
is at their head.
What that means is that he's going out first and he
is going out publicly.
I don't know about you. But when I read that the first time through
my Jesus lenses when I looked at that, I don't know where your mind
went, but my mind went to Jesus busting out
of that grave alive on the third day.
when he broke open the breach your king goes out first
because what I know in second Corinthians 2:14, is
that when Jesus did that he was leading out a triumphal
procession it says
You know what? That is. That's a Victory Parade.
That's where he is on the front car or
whatever. He's riding. It's White Horse. Let's just say that way
right he's on the front of the parade. He's coming down the street and
everybody's cheering to clap and say there's the winner. There's the
Victor. That's who he is.
And you know, who else is in that parade?
Man, this is good news. There's there's other people in that parade,
right?
Because he says it here.
That as his headship as his first
fruits of the Resurrection comes out and
he's the Victor showing Deliverance Deliverance for
who just for him. No for all the people in the parade with
him.
That all of those who trusted in his life death and
Resurrection are in that Eternal Victory Parade with
him.
like you see that
that he busted out of the prison of sin and shame and death and
he's leading us to come out with him.
And listen, it doesn't matter if you're rich or poor.
it doesn't matter if you
feel oppressed or have been treated negatively or whatever. It
doesn't matter if you've been the oppressor.
If you have repented and believed in Jesus,
then you are in that parade.
With King Jesus at your head at
the front with him leading you out you are in that
parade by faith in Jesus.
Is that not the most satisfying place to be?
When we look around we see the mess of life. We see our
own struggles. This is the most satisfying place to
be believe that church.
believe that
Again, I know some of you have gone through such horrific things
experiences. You've been told certain things about you.
believe this
that you're in that parade by faith in Christ.
Believe that the Victor the winner is
on the front of that parade and he's leading you
out of that prison of sin and shame and questions and
doubts and struggles and all of the past. He's leading you
out of it one day. This is coming Church.
So let that reality.
Lead you out of the prison that you're walking in right now.
Whatever you feel trapped by.
Whatever you're worried about whatever you're afraid of whatever you're
holding on to from the past. Let this reality that
Jesus Is the Victor leads you out of that prison,
too.
right now
First for sin that you're trapped in the prison of
sin and death. You can't get out of yourself. Let him Lead You Out by
faith, but then everything else in your life.
This is who?
opens the gate
for you to walk out of into freedom.
But what that should lead you to shouldn't stop with that.
It's for you as you're walking in that Victory Parade.
For you to turn around and be able to not push
down other people to get what you want anymore, but
to pull them up with you.
To lift them up and invite them into the parade with
you and say come with me follow our King.
Let me help you. Let me support you. Let me love you. Well, as he's loved
me that's the response day to
day.
King has one the eternal battle. There's nothing for
us to worry about he's hymning Us in he's caring for us and
he'll take us home one day and throw a party for us.
Thankful for that, but let's live in light of that today.